[Music]
in the fall of 1960 Francis Oldham
Kelsey was one of the Food and Drug
Administration's newest recruits before
the year is out she would begin a fight
that would save thousands of lives
though no one knew it at the time
although she was new to the FDA Kelsey
was no novice as a scientist after
graduating from high school at age 15
she enrolled at McGill University in
Montreal and earned both undergraduate
and master's degrees in pharmacology
from there she applied for a research
post at the university of chicago's
pharmacology department her acceptance
letter was addressed to mr. Oldham
Kelsey leader joked that had her name
been Elizabeth or Mary Jane her career
might have ended there fortunately it
didn't she earned her doctorate in
pharmacology and accepted Chicago's
invitation to stay as faculty where she
undertook pioneering research on drugs
and feel safety in 1950 she earned an MD
her fourth and final degree by the time
she joined the FDA Frances Kelsey was
one of the most educated experienced
scientists around yet as the newest
member of the team Kelsey was assigned
what everyone thought would be an easy
review an application from the u.s. drug
company Meryl to sell a drug called
thalidomide thalidomide was a sedative
developed in Germany that was already
being widely used in dozens of countries
to treat insomnia and workplace stress
thalidomide anti-nausea properties also
made it a popular remedy for pregnant
women with morning sickness reviewing
Merrill's application Kelsey found its
data on thalidomide
absorption and toxicity inadequate today
the FDA Classifieds drugs based on their
safety for our fetus but in 1960 many
experts believe that the placental
barrier shielded a fetus from harm
Kelsey's earlier animal based research
demonstrated the opposite drugs could
pass from mother to fetus through the
placenta like other drug companies at
this time Meryl had not tested its drug
on pregnant animals Kelsey later said
Merrill's evidence for thalidomide
safety seemed more like testimonials
than the results of well-designed
studies
Kelsey rejected Merrill's application
and asked them to submit a second backed
by better evidence her FDA colleagues
supported this decision Merrill had
expected a quick affirmative reply so it
could launch the Linum ID for the
holiday season when sedative sales soar
instead of supplying kalsi with the data
she requested they first tried to
convince her to approve the drug over a
series of calls and visits when these
failed to sway her Merrill executives
complained that stubborn and nitpicking
Kelsey was the problem not Selena Meyer
the FDA backed calcium forcing Meryl to
file another application and another and
another
as Kelsey reviewed and rejected each new
application news of the Lynne amides
adverse side effects began to surface
doctors reported cases of nerve damage
in early 1961 and by fall they'd
unmasked a more horrible truth falooda
Meyde widely used by pregnant women
caused severe birth defects thousands of
babies died in utero and tens of
thousands more were born with extra
appendages shorter limbs or no limbs at
all in November 1961 thalidomide was
pulled from the German market
nonetheless Merrill continued trying to
get it approved in the US for several
months before withdrawing their sixth
and final application while Kelsey
wasn't the only scientist to identify
the risks of the Ludum I she sounded the
alarm that kept it off the
multibillion-dollar American drug market
as public awareness of the thalidomide
tragedy grew the quiet scientists became
a media sensation headlines and
newspapers and magazines heralded her
heroism while a smiling President John F
Kennedy presented her an award on the
White House lawn after the thalidomide
scare Congress passed laws that expanded
the FDA's Authority and toughened
requirements for new drug applications
Kelsey was tapped to head the agency's
drug investigation branch working at the
FDA in different capacities into her 90s
Kelsey was able to witness the changes
her actions helped inspire her
visibility may have dimmed since but her
legacy indoors privileges over opinions
and patience over short cuts she made
evidence-based medicine the foundation
of reforms that continue to protect
people today we are inspired by Frances
Kelsey story and we hope you are too
but dr. Kelsey's life-saving work was
almost thwarted by the pervasive gender
biases of the 1930s when offered her job
at the University of Chicago
she felt pressured to refuse it because
according to dr. Kelsey when a woman
took a job in those days she was made to
feel as if she was depriving a man of
the ability to support his wife and
child today women make up almost 40% of
the world's paid workforce but they are
still disproportionately unrepresented
in STEM fields why these students in our
ted-ed clubs program are asking the same
question and many are using the platform
to share their scientific ideas
discoveries and hopes with the world
make space for your passion and join the
movement to promote student ideas visit
Edie ted.com / clubs to learn more
[Music]